So the main thing is acquiring words
so that I understand more things
so that when I'm listening to it,
I find more words that I recognize.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today
and I'm going to talk about the most
important goal in language learning,
in other words, how to learn words.
Language learning has always in my mind
being about acquiring words and I'm
going to explain what I mean by that.
And you'll remember that I made
this one video about the seven most
important goals in language learning.
And number one is learning words.
If you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast.
Uh, please leave a comment.
First of all, um, because there was a
number of people commented on how my
microphone was a bit of a distraction.
Uh, I'm trying to set up here in such
a way oriented with my camera that
you don't see the, um, microphone.
I hope that is the case.
In fact, I will check on that right now.
I think I can do that here,
if you bear very with me...
and yeah.
Microphone is out of view.
Also, uh, I'm going to do, I mentioned in
that previous video where I talked about
the seven goals, uh, of language learning,
I'm going to go through each goal and
talk about how we, in fact, learn words.
For example, today I did a video about
how I learned Ukrainian, and I'm going
to continue doing videos about how
I learned these different languages.
Um, I wasn't happy with the video
I did about learning Ukrainian
because I know I have a number of
books at home in Vancouver, and
I wanted to show these to you.
So I'm going to either use that
video or redo the video, uh, a month
from now when I'm home in Vancouver.
Uh, but I will be...
and so if you're interested in hearing
how I learned the different languages, let
me know which languages you're interested
in hearing about and I will try to make
videos about how I learned them, to the
what degree, in fact, I did learn them.
So words, when we designed LingQ, it
was designed around the idea that to
me, the simplest measure of where you
are in the language is how many words
you know, and that the task of learning
languages is one of learning words.
And I remember that, I remember that
when we learned French at school
and I really couldn't speak French.
But, um, when I was, I was actually at
a football game, professional football,
Montreal Alouettes, and I lost my ticket
and I was explaining to the, uh, usher
in French and after 10 years of French,
all I could do is put together words.
I couldn't use the verbs
correctly ... uh, you know, just words.
And I think that the easiest
thing to acquire is words.
And if we have enough words, we
actually can do a lot with those words
and that the refinement with, with
grammar and so forth comes later.
So, and therefore, when we designed
LingQ, we built all kinds of things
into LingQ that measure how many words
you've read, how many words you've
learned, how many words, you know,
how many words you've looked up.
Uh, we have different highlighting to tell
you what stage you are with that word.
So words, um, most of the words you
acquire, you're going to acquire
subconsciously by being exposed to them.
And it's difficult to tell when certain
words will click in, uh, some you learn
fast and some take forever to remember
some we remember, and then we forget
again, and then we remember them again.
That's all fine.
But initially you say, if you're
on LingQ and you've got a page
of text in a new language, let's
say Finnish for me or Icelandic
or something, everything is blue.
And I have to look up every single
blue word and ideally I do it in
sentence mode so I'm not having to
deal with too much content at once.
And slowly, all of a sudden, each
one of these blue words, I looked
them up and they are now all yellow.
And because each language has a different
structure uh, the word order and so forth
may not be the same as English, but I can
kind of figure out what the sentence says.
Very often there's a translation
underneath, into English in my case.
Uh, and so I'm on my way to getting a
grasp of the language, I'm on my way
to acquiring words, the ultimate goal,
if we use again LingQ as the example is
that the whole lesson page will be white.
That the word...
the blue words will have become
yellow words because I looked them
up and I mean, you know, I'm trying
to learn these words, but eventually
these words do become known.
When they're known they're white.
And I noticed that over months or so,
because any word, once I've learned
it and it's become white, it will show
up white in every subsequent lesson.
And any word that went from blue to yellow
will be yellow in any subsequent lesson.
So there's a gradual process of making
these pages lighter and lighter in colour.
Now, some people say, oh, and I
should also point out that the
only thing we can measure at
LingQ is your passive vocabulary.
And I I've said this before in,
in videos, I'm a great believer in
the power of passive vocabulary.
I'm a great believer in
input, in comprehension.
So we, when we see a word in a
context and we understand that
word in that context at least in my
case, I consider that word known.
It is known in that context.
It is known passively.
It doesn't mean that I can use
the word, but I'm on my way.
And it may be that in another
context, I'll see that word
and I won't know what it means.
And then I'll simply move it
back to unknow, to status one.
It doesn't matter because the
process of acquiring words is largely
subconscious and it's largely a process
of being exposed to these words.
Now, some people will say, phrases are
more important than words, and I do save
a lot of phrases, but you have to know the
meaning of the words inside the phrase.
When you see phrases with words that
naturally belong together, you can then
save that phrase and try to remember
that phrase so that you have a handy
ready to use phrase with the way these
words are normally used in the language.
But the fundamental
job is acquiring words.
And if you don't need to look a word
up, LingQ will assume that you know
it, So another thing you often hear
people say is, well, you don't really
need many words because, uh, 70% of
any context, you know, is gonna consist
of 500, 800, 1000 most common words.
That's true.
But if you only ever want to have very
limited conversations with people,
if you don't ever want to understand
books or movies, maybe that's fine.
But most people, certainly in my
case, when I learn a language,
I want to understand movies.
I want to have intelligent
conversations with people.
To do all of that I have to have a large
passive vocabulary, not just a thousand
words, 10,000 words, 20,000, 30,000.
That enables me then to listen to
a variety of different content,
podcasts, movies, and all of that
is helping the language come into
me and most of all I am driven by
the desire to acquire more words.
Now, some people like using spaced
repetition systems, I don't, because
I don't want to spend so much time
going through these decks of words.
Also.
I'm not a big fan of flashcards, but
other people do use them and swear
by them and think they're great.
And so that's fine.
I'm not against them, but
even at LingQ where we have
flashcards, different activities.
I sometimes do them, but mostly
I just work with lists, uh, in
every lesson behind every lesson
page, behind every sentence I can
review the words from that page.
I can review the LingQs, words
that I'm trying to learn.
I can review words that
I have never seen before.
Blue words.
I can review words that I have
long since moved to known.
I can review them if I want.
I like seeing words in lists.
Lists to me are better than
flashcards because you can
see more of them more quickly.
And to me, reviewing words is
just another form of exposure.
It gives you another kind of
activity where you are being exposed
to the language, and with lists
there are a number of advantages.
You can go through the list
alphabetically so then you start to
see words that have the same prefix.
Very often you'll start to
see connections between words.
You'll see that you have saved three, four
or five, six words that begin the same
way and maybe share some common meaning.
I find that very helpful.
Uh, you can review your words
in lists based on frequency.
And if you like, I'm often motivated to
move some of the words that I have saved,
and I have a lot of them in all the
languages, I want to move them to known.
So if I take my high-frequency words,
I'm more likely to find words there that
I actually already know, but I haven't
had a chance to move them to known.
So I'll go in there and I'll
move a bunch of words to known.
It's good for my known words total, and
also for my learned words total on LingQ.
Another thing you can do with
lists is...yeah well, let's
move on to another subject here.
Words have different
functions in the sentence.
So even without knowing, say, all of the
conjugations of verbs, at least we're
aware that there are words that are verbs.
There are words that are nouns.
There are words that are adjectives,
adverbs are conjunctions, in
other words connecting words.
So we can tag for these.
Um, and this is helpful because then you
can go to your vocabulary section and you
go through just verbs or just adjectives.
And you can start to see things
that these adjectives or verbs
or whatever have in common.
Another thing is it may be that
in some languages, you have
trouble with a third person of the
past tense you can tag for that.
So you can look at the third person of
the past tense only as a list or you
might, if languages that have cases, you
can look at just the instrumental case,
let's say in Russian or Slavic languages.
And you can just review those.
So lists to my mind are more useful
in terms of reviewing for exposure
then flashcards, because I'm not
actually that interested in racking my
brain to try and remember something.
I don't actually believe
that that's all that useful.
So the main thing is acquiring words so
that I understand more things so that
when I'm listening to it, I find more
words that I recognize, even if I'm
fuzzy on the grammar, the words generally
speaking, the meaning is redundant.
So even without having a full knowledge
of the grammar, you can kind of figure
out the meaning if you have the words.
So goal number one to me is acquiring
words, acquiring them naturally
varying your activity so that you
can sometimes get tired of reading
and, and saving words and phrases.
And so you can go through lists
of words for different reasons
in order to maybe move the status
to known or whatever it might be.
And so, as you progress in the
language and particularly when you get
past sort of the first stage in the
language, because again, remember that
frequency declines very, very quickly.
So in an initial period, you're seeing
words quite often, you don't have to
worry about aceing the most, the 500
most frequent words in the language.
They're frequent, they will show
up, you needn't worry about them.
And the frequency declines
very, very quickly.
And so pretty soon we're into a
space, what I've called the sort
of long, uh, you know, shaft of the
hockey stick, where it, we feel as
if we're not making any progress.
We're not seeing these words as
often as we used to, because the
words we now need are less frequent.
And that's where again, on LingQ,
where we keep track of how many
words you've learned, how many words
you've known, how many LingQs you've
created, how many words you've read.
This tells you that you are being active,
that you are pursuing these words.
And if you are pursuing these
words, you will improve.
You will acquire the language because
to pursue these words, you've got
to be it listening and reading.
If you're listening and
reading and pursuing words,
the language is coming in you.
So to summarize, number one goal in
language learning is to acquire words,
keep that as your goal, keep that as your,
your major activity, be conscious of the
fact that you are acquiring these words.
Even though at times it seems
that you can't remember them.
You can't remember when
you need to use them.
You keep on forgetting their meaning.
None of that matters.
If you continue to pursue words,
you will eventually achieve your
goal insofar as words are concerned.
And your goal insofar as
achieving fluencies is concerned.
So thank you for listening.
That was the first in the series
on the seven most important
goals in language learning.
Bye for now.